Anna what's up hey how you doing I'm
good how are you good welcome so it says
that uh you don't agree that you'll
share a high Valley man so is this a
disagreement with something that I've
said or is this just a statement no no
um I think
he asked me like what was one thing that
stood out and it did stick stick in my
brain from the show that I did with um
the other show and
you heard if you heard any of it I
agreed with almost everything that they
talk upon with regards to the women that
lack empathy etc etc one thing I will
not do and I don't there's no
justification behind it this is just
also my personal perspective in my
culture
the way we operate women definitely do
not openly share and we say openly
unfortunately the men are known to cheat
in my culture but if we don't openly
share and we're not
bred or brought up to say okay I welcome
four or five different women it's just
not gonna happen so my background is
Basque uh Scottish and Cuban
ask that's the best country north of
Spain and France
okay oratory is it or a kingdom yes it's
a region yeah yeah they've always they I
mean if you're from there they've always
been you know fighting so and so forth
you know separate themselves which is
why it's called Basque country but yes
it is it's attached to in a part of
Spain and France so that's just the one
thing that I didn't agree with with
Myron and I I again it's personal
preference I just I'm not good at
sharing and I don't feel like I need to
from me yeah let me ask you all I hear
is drama that just says drama yes that's
a talking point that you'll hear from a
lot of the Mano swamp type of creators
where they're like high value men you
know should be able to cheat or they
should be able to get away with it blah
blah blah sort of thing and I think the
part that's that's missing so you said
that what did you say exactly something
along the lines of
um you don't openly do it right so yeah
so in our culture
um we protect the house and the husband
or the man of the house always knows and
this is something we were what we were
brought up with and again it's not that
we openly accepted
it's just understood that as long as the
house is you know
and it's reserved then no one can
obviously permeate you know permeate
through the walls and it's not a glass
house on some point we're good we're
golden it's got we have to stay strong
if if anyone if any woman can come and
in and basically blow down our house
it's like a house of cards so it was
always known that men in our culture
will cheat have a mistress have their
second home sometimes it's but they'll
never they're never gonna leave or put
that woman first before the primary wife
it's just not the case
but you'd be okay with that it's not
that I would be okay or not okay it's
the point is I cannot control everything
a man's gonna do he's gonna do whatever
he wants and the more power the more
money and the more status he has it
comes with the territory so going as far
as saying you know your movie starring
an a-lister and these girls think that
they're gonna date someone and be the
only girl on his roster that's what you
don't understand you're on a roster so
the more money the more status the more
likely he's gonna have you times 20
times 100. for me that's why they asked
oh would you go for a mediocre man
it's not going for a mediocre man or or
settling it's I know where I stand I
know I'm first of all right now I know
I'm older but even when I was uh as
young as the other girl Gabriella was
I've always been this way I've always
dated older men even when I was in my
early 20s I've always been uh more
attracted to the brain and I've always
been a sapiosexual person
okay explain what a sapiosexual is uh
sapiosexual for me you know it's I'm
turned on by the brain and I've always
been attracted to someone's passion for
knowledge and and the success of of
their passion so for me if I see a man
in power I'm I'm completely attracted to
that and I then I just I have to be
careful so it's not that you're
attracted to his brain that you're more
attracted to his influence and his
status then right
well for me I consider success the power
of the brain so the more intelligent
they are from me I consider that to be
more successful and Powerful okay
um how old are you Anna 40 41 now okay
and you said you've dated a lot of older
guys have yeah they all cheated on you
like have you guys uh no not all of them
the majority have so my picker's always
been off so definitely I would never be
able to give that type of advice the
only thing I can tell you is I've
learned what I do not want and I
definitely
do not want someone in my culture it's
just I already know what they're like
and that's what I stay away from Latinos
not I don't do well with them I prefer
American men and the ones that I haven't
cheated unfortunately I just haven't
been in the right
um time in my life it has been the right
chapter in my life so it's been
unfortunate so let me pose a scenario to
you meet a guy he ticks off all the
boxes you know he's
okay he's got them all you guys moving
together you've got a household
okay you're now living together
he sometimes steps out
he doesn't do it to embarrass you he
doesn't take some random mistress to a
restaurant that he takes you to he won't
take her anywhere where one of your
friends might see it and takes a a
picture and texts you and says hey Anna
look look look who he's with over here
look what he's doing he doesn't go out
of his way to embarrass you right but he
but he comes home to you he loves you he
takes care of everything takes care of
the kids all this sort of stuff
is that a a problem for you is that
something that you would be I mean you
would be excited about it but would you
proceed would you stay with him
depends on the uh it depends on the
circumstances do we have children
children for me are more of a priorities
to this Legacy and unfortunately yeah
let's say what let's say you guys have
kids
um
I would have to weigh out the the
situation for sure I would definitely
the way out the situation I mean
Fairview takes care of the house I would
be lying to you I'd be lying to you if I
didn't say for sure I would not take
them back I'd be lying because I don't
know I don't know so like
here's the thing right because sharing a
guy knowingly being embarrassed about it
that's the part that seems to get the
gals right is you don't want to be
embarrassed
I don't want the drama I'm not going to
go drama you know you're all showing up
at your front door knocking on it going
pregnant with his baby right no I don't
right
so it's the embarrassment Factor
for me absolutely I I I have a sense of
Pride and I'm okay with making sure that
the house is always protected I can't
teach a kid my kids to not follow in
that footsteps I can't teach my kid to
be strong based on lies yeah it'll be
alive because I have a chapter in my
book where I talk about things like
monogamy and
non-monogamy and stuff like that and
it's like
throughout history the most successful
guys have always had access to more
women because they're successful right
and we know that women like I'm sure you
have girlfriends that would rather date
a married guy than to be with a loser
that lives in his mom's basement right
because I'm not going to reference that
subject because that was a whole another
subject yeah but yes right yeah yeah no
that's why I'm saying like all the men
in my family again when I say they're
successful I don't know what they've
done I don't know if they've stepped out
do we do I doubt that they have or
haven't or have thought about it or have
had maybe some conversations or they've
been attacked I don't know is it likely
probably the problem the probability is
extremely high women extremely high so
women don't get excited if it's overt if
it's if it's rubbed in your face if you
you know if you come home and there's
another woman's panties in your bed I
mean if you see like a hair somewhere
yeah don't bring anything right don't
bring anything
this universe this universe keeps on
getting larger
women and men go somewhere else don't
bring any diseases home don't bring
anything for me like I said to you yeah
for me it's a it's a health risk because
I have a house with children and myself
and I also do not want to have to
explain things when the child should
just be living as a child learn what you
need to learn which is learn survival
learn to be a kid learn how to be a
teenager learn how to be a young adult
learn how to respect your Authority your
authorities and go from there but if you
don't know how to handle that how can
you teach your kid one thing from one
side of your face and then show them
something else on the outside of your
face it's very difficult to do very
difficult do you have children from a
past marriage no but every single person
that I've dated on a serious like that
I've taken very seriously and considered
marriage have had children
um even when I was extremely young my ex
had an 18 year old and I was in my early
20s which is extremely difficult to do
and then the one that didn't have
children he
um had cancer and we our conversations
were more about if we do have children
what are we looking at are we looking at
you passing it to them am I going to be
um a widow am I my level of conversation
has always been a little different so I
can't expect everyone to understand how
I think so to answer all of your
questions I'm a little bit
on another level with regards to how
I've
I guess had my experiences dealt to me
on the cards that I've been done but I
mean like at the end of the day humans
aren't very good at monogamy we're kind
of monogamish we're more of a one person
at a time sort of species right that is
uh I think that's the best way to see it
is definitely one person at a time I've
always told girls that guys can love a
lot of women but women are not built
that same way exactly and I mean like
see here's the thing like the argument
goes I don't want to share a guy but in
the past you've definitely shared guys
as yeah a lot of women most women in
fact it's it's very very rare that
you're going to get a guy and a gal that
hair Bond have intimacy get married have
a family and they never share their
bodies with anybody else it's very rare
now today
anybody's ever said that yeah well yeah
I'm sure it happens in some strong
religion culture really I'm gonna say
strong religious questions things like
that you know certain parts of the world
you got certain regions like maybe in
Greenland maybe in Antarctica well
they're pretty promiscuous up in
Greenland and Iceland really oh yeah
very promiscuous in those cultures
especially in Iceland this is new to me
Iceland is the only capital of the world
outside of the United States what is it
Iceland it's one of the single mommy
capitals of the world where there's a
lot of kids coming from others anyway
um so so the point that you kicked off
was you know that you're not down with
sharing but you're okay with sharing
provided it's not really in your face
there's no disease you're not
embarrassed and you've got a strong
relationship with a guy it's not an
ongoing thing right like it's not like
no fellas where it's like Saturday
nights with Anna and Friday nights no no
no what I mean is what I mean what I
mean and this is because I've been
through this where where I had to decide
am I going to be able to deal with this
because if I forgive him I'm walking
down the the slippery slope up he'll
probably do it again so
I'm not one to say okay go ahead you're
gonna have your your fun and you're
gonna have your hall pass constantly or
once a month no not at all it's if he
slips and we get past it great if it
makes us stronger awesome
um do I think I'm gonna leave him if he
messes up
probably not if he's extremely
successful with the way I I love men to
just be super successful it's just it's
what attracts me to them it's something
that's going to come with the territory
now am I going to like I said am I gonna
be happy with him having me and then
another chick permanently I'm not I'm
not sure I'm good with it anymore I'm
I'm at an age where I'm just and it's
not even that I'm old it's just I'm at
an age where I just don't feel like it I
just don't feel like it so yes it might
be a lonely road but I mean thank God I
look at 40 right now okay now what what
is your dating strategy at 40 right now
like what are you looking for let's see
my dating strategy is definitely where I
have a long longer list of what I will
not put up with and
with everything that I've experienced
and everyone that I've learned from and
everything that I learned from I always
end up offering more and my network and
the net worth of my network always
brings more value so my valuation of the
quality has shifted to where can I hang
out with this person and care okay so
let's do a little bit of a sales pitcher
right okay because we've got your
Instagram here at the bottom okay so
Anna is is signal single so what is it
that you bring to the table for a man
today
today the only thing I know for a fact
that I bring more than than most chicks
is my my experience and knowledge of the
no [__] drama I don't do drama two is
my family are very well known in my in
the city so that's always a plus because
that last story you taught you talked
about there's no [__] way I'm gonna
live with someone's mother I'm just not
gonna do it second let's see third on
the list is what I just said the network
of people for opportunities for the
different
um factors of business I can probably
introduce them to somebody that will do
business with them okay well let me just
stop you for a sec so you like
you're talking about no drama you're
talking about boundaries but you haven't
really said what you what you bring to
the table though
uh I bring to the table let me see um
you want to be very Frank I'm extremely
good in bed uh let's see
um so is Every Other Woman Anna I don't
care about them I care about me you
asked about me I really don't care about
them I can give three [__] about them I
care about what I bring to the table and
if they're willing to sit across me so
I'm just wondering you know what the
extra umph is you know that you're that
you're offering meant today
actually
um the one thing I don't like drama
drama for me is a big thing and they
don't realize that until they have it in
their face constantly because that's
what they do that's why they also change
girls as soon as their drama they go to
the next one
you do realize though that you're not
bringing anything new or different to
the table than what other women do like
every woman will say I'm the best in bed
everyone will say oh no no I didn't say
that especially over the age of about 35
40 they start saying things like I don't
do drama right so you're not you're not
bringing anything new to the table here
that I'm I mean I mean I'm trying to
sell you to my audience Anna right like
we got your Instagram no you're fine the
thing is one thing I can't I can't I
can't lie to you is I'm not the I'm not
obviously
at the age that most of the guys that
your audience would want so I've already
dealt with all that and I don't really
I'm never gonna lie to them I'm not for
everyone I am not going to perceive
myself rely on myself saying I'm the
best out there because no one's they're
still looking guys are always going to
be looking and even what they think is
the best they're still gonna always be
looking so I'm never going to be worried
that I'm bringing something more or
better than the next girl I could give
three [__] about what she's bringing
the person that likes me is gonna like
me and I'm fine with that if they don't
like me go to the next girl and I'll
literally point you in the right
direction I'm gonna make the man that
I'm with feel like an alpha and I'm
gonna make sure that he has no problems
until the day he wants to leave and
that's it I just know that
I'm good I'm good I can cook I can clean
I can do laundry
um I'm good in bed I may not be the best
because I'm never gonna I don't know
what the best is and I don't know my
best might be best to him but other than
that
um no kids no baggage that's a good
thing and at my age for my age and let's
see
um I probably can help them with their
business most chicks can't do that at my
age because they're too selfish most of
them are
um I don't know what do you do something
why do you do this why don't you give me
a checklist
and I'll tell you the truth if I fit it
or don't fit it for what a guide
considers
no one percenter well let's let the
suitors DM you that uh so the so last
question I have for you is what do you
do for a living so I Source I sourced
raw land for commercial uh developer so
industrial and then
um I also do a lot of Consulting on the
side
for people that don't know how to run
their business because they're running
it into the ground and then the fitness
modeling I had to stop it after I had a
um an odd accident
um close to a year ago and I got hit in
the head so I had to deal with that
all right
fellas if you if you dig Anna's Vibe
there's her Instagram hit her up she's
she's single she's she's single and
ready to mingle all right boys you are
terrible you're horrible
but thanks I appreciate it thank you
welcome thanks Anna I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out